competitive eater tactics break down
the challenge into proteins fiber carbs
and
pray pray that you make it to the end
my name is leah shutkiver and i'm the
uk's number one
female competitive eater a professional
competitive eater
in my view is somebody who is paid to
compete in food challenges i've been
eating professionally
since 2015. my official guinness world
records titles
are the fastest time to eat a burrito at
35 seconds
fastest time to eat three pickled eggs
7.8 seconds
fastest time to eat three mince pies 52
seconds fastest time to eat a teres
chocolate orange at 65 seconds
the craziest thing that i've ever done
and i thought okay i'm gonna go to a
restaurant i'm going to order two
platters of food which was made for
eight people
it took me around 48 minutes
and it was around 12
000 calories like pretty massive
so today we're at polo 24-hour bar and
i'm going to be taking on
this incredible looking burger stack
there are six
burgers stacked very very tall and with
a portion of fries at the base
they look fully loaded beef burgers
lettuce pickles bacon cheese
some sort of relish and wow they just
they smell incredible but
very intimidating and hopefully he's got
a big appetite because he'll need it
i've been the worst man three times i'm
britain's strongest man
english strongest man uk strongest man
the pressure is there but i like
pressure
i also love food as part of the strong
man to be challenged
in eating as well as lifting heavy
weights and i think that's something i
can really give a good goal to do
[Music]
bye
i was a big kid like quite sturdy you
know like
high school was savage i was
bullied i was so badly bullied people
would call me
like fat and ugly and make fun of me for
looking different
my head was like i need to be
skinny i would say that bodybuilding
was the best form of therapy for me i
know exactly what i need to do
to contra the craziness that is compared
to eating without the gym i wouldn't be
where i am because i wouldn't feel
confident enough that i'd be able to
maintain my weight and my physique
whatever it is that makes you tick that
makes you
passionate just do it just do really
well because if you do it really well
no one's gonna question you
two one
oh slippery devils away
wow
you're right though um
don't put me off i can see what you're
doing
this is so dense i can't even like begin
to
oh yeah trying to miss them off the side
it never ends
wow the first burger was amazing the
taste is
unbelievable but you've got that densely
that big
patty and then all the bits and bobs
going on with it as well
it's my jaw that hurts i'm not hurt but
it's like a pump
a small small bit small bits greys just
pick
i look cleaner than i am i think the
first buyer just got sourced all over
my face got stuck in here
and it's just been downhill for a while
oh my gosh
that's hard
competitive eater tactics break down the
challenge
into proteins carbs and then everything
else in between
go proteins fiber carbs and
prey
yeah i actually did that the first
burger it didn't work
it just it doesn't seem like a lot since
we went from there
to here probably one of the hardest
challenges i've done oh my god for that
i've given rob some my chip style oh
thanks i really need a few more this is
lovely but i could do loads of these
we're still eating still going
you got this don't you need to eat oh
yeah yeah i mean
loads of chips even when you take the
burger patty away
it's still a massive burger
i'm done i'm just full up
come to a foodie challenge of this
magnitude
and this way with her i got beaten by
the best
let's say very well done
very well done winning feels amazing and
a lot of the time
if you're quite fast you can demoralize
even the biggest eaters it is just a fun
sport
i've never been more confident or happy
in myself and what i'm doing ever in my
entire life any more fancy dessert
i could probably probably a dessert hi
my name's steve nichols
i'm a veteran six months ago i sat down
with an older veteran on the gap
when soldiers come back home someone
looks at the wrong way you're already in
fight mode
it's been 12 years i'm still in fight
mode now well you've been through quite
a lot son haven't you
we compared our stories and our lives
and it's crazy